- I love your costume.
- Hi!
(audience applauds)
- Hello!
- Have you ever met Megan?
- No, oh my gosh.
- She wrote me
a letter though.
- What?
- I did.
- She's so sweet, I got a
letter in my room from her.
- I left you one as well.
- Oh my gosh, wait, I have never seen,
but wait, we actually have
proof that she is a super fan.
We have a clip of this.
This is true, watch.
♪ be replaced ♪
♪ Nah, I come from outer space ♪
♪ I'm a classy girl, I'ma hold it up ♪
♪ You full of something
but it ain't love ♪
♪ What we got was straight overdue ♪
♪ Go find somebody new ♪
(audience cheering)
Oh, my gosh.
(Meghan laughing)
That's the cutest thing
in the entire world,
I love how you're just like
wiping someone away with your sass.
How old were you?
- I didn't know that my
mom send that to you guys
- How old were you?
until this morning.
- You're welcome,
we paid her well.
- Oh my gosh.
- So wait, what, how old were you?
- I don't even know. I was
probably like eight or nine.
I was on the way to cheer
practice. (laughing)
- Oh my gosh, so cute.
So, real fan, she knew the whole thing.
- Oh yeah.
- I'm her number one fan,
though, like, Handmaid's Tail?
- Oh my gosh.
- Pshh.
Well, look at this
- Everything.
beautiful love fest.
- Oh, my god.
- Superstar.
(audience applauding)
- I love it.
- I feel honored.
I love video footage of
little kids singing raps.